there's a lot more to mass than just
numbers eddi-rue is the high school
teacher everyone wishes they had his
parents wanted him to be a doctor or a
lawyer but his calling was in the
classroom and he's been teaching maths
for 10 years
what we used to calculate Eddy appeared
as a guest speaker at the New South
Wales business chambers first education
forum to share his experiences in the
classroom and talk about how the
education system could be improved for
students and their teachers my dream
classroom is a collaborative space where
students are working in groups where
they've got spaces where they can move
off to the side focus on a problem on
their own come together with their
friends be facilitated by a teacher who
understands them understands what makes
them tick and can help them grow in the
skills that they need mr. Wu is one of
eighty four thousand qualified school
teachers across the state caring for
more than 1.2 million students from
kindergarten through to year 12 every
day the quality of teachers and their
teaching is clearly decisive in our
schools and in their learning outcomes
that our students are able to achieve
making sure we get the best people to
become teachers is a huge problem and if
there was an easy solution we would have
found it already teachers are leaving
the profession in significant numbers
latest figures revealed 53 percent of
people with a teaching degree do not
work in education and almost 50% of new
teachers leave the profession in the
first five years the problem is that
once upon a time teachers were held in
very high regard up there with doctors
and and others in our community and I
often hear the expression from people
these days you'll hear you'll hear a
joke made which is those who can do
those who can't teach and I think the
whole issue about teaching has become
domaine to an extent that you know now
that I've got five kids and I go to my
kids schools the most precious thing
that they do is to teach my children and
we need to be investing much more
heavily in getting people who are
suitable to be teachers have a passion
for teaching ever have a s an aptitude
for it we need to be rewarding them we
need to be making sure that they're
valued we need to make sure their status
is appreciated by society the Education
Forum brought together business leaders
educators and changemakers with the aim
of transforming school education
aside from cloning Eddie coming up with
real solutions to attract and retain
quality teachers is central to the
future success of education in New South
Wales teaching matters you know teaching
makes a huge difference to the lives of
individual students I can see a direct
causal whine between the time that I
spend understanding concepts wrapping my
head around what's the clearest way to
explain this and help students
experience it themselves I can see a
direct line from that effort and the
experience of my students in the
classroom and where they go after school
which is just amazing
[Music]